long story short we shot this movie on
red red has a special codec it sits in
raw and what that means is that rather
than saving an image it saves the data
coming up the sensor so the only things
that are baked into your footage are
your focus your shutter speed and your
aperture basically your exposure
everything else can be completely
changed after the fact so it's really
useful now here's the thing we're like
yo post house
why don't we edit in raw that way we can
change all these settings if we need to
we're working full resolution files you
don't have to re online and replace
files if we can do it on a YouTube
channel we can do it on a movie they're
like that's great love the idea we agree
like sweet and like hmm those files look
kind of low res and weird editing with
proxies I'm like but what happened to
working in the Rozz and they're like ah
yeah you're right also we need to do
some editing on this because it's gonna
be easiest for us to get in our vision
if we can sit down and edit for a while
I got Viggo the longest story it's like
does anyone care though that's the
question
see Sam the trick is I can tell a long
story through the magic of editing it
becomes a short spur like can you please
send us a hard drive and I got it and so
I sent us a Mac Drive files reconnected
except no audio is reconnected I can you
guys focus something something else
once again they sent us another Mac
Drive we told them our own pcs and so we
called them up like guys we don't have a
computer that can read this and they're
like oh ok we'll just send you a Mac a
good friend of ours decided to buy us
all plane tickets to come see him at the
Sundance Film Festival in Utah it
happens to also be Jake's birthday so
yeah Jake gets a birthday plane ride
have any birthday wishes for me please
in the comments I'm just looking forward
to seeing some cool movies maybe a
little skiing
that is a big line let's all sit next to
each other we'll say no like I don't
care anymore
single sexy
let's go this movie is really boring
Kenneth had like that means just
everyone for option please 10 out of 10
is Code Red for leaving and I love this
little go problem just a little girl
problem okay you should toss it around
I think I Carmichael runner-up to in the
studio right now